foreign
[Music]
I just wanted to inform you that we've
published all conclusions just now on
our website I invite the president of
the European Parliament oh
ladies and gentlemen
good day to all
uh to all of you and it's a great
pleasure to see so many of you here in
uh person for this press conference let
me Begin by talking but just before I
begin about uh the content I would like
to begin by warmly thanking the Swedish
presidency through the person of its
prime minister for a very methodical
active energetic and serious presidency
we had great cooperation throughout the
presidency and I'm sure that wolf when
he makes his presentation in a few
minutes we'll be able to say that a lot
of progress has has been made we know
that the geopolitical context is
difficult Unity is essential unity in
support of Ukraine our ability to move
forward in terms of Transforming Our
economic model taking account of the
digital
transformation uh these are issues of
great import to the member states to the
presidency to the council and and the
commission thank you very much again
tool for this excellent presidency and
all the work that has been done coming
out of the European Council we had a
quite a heavy agenda in terms of the
substance
so I will try to focus on what I think
are the key points firstly the war in
Ukraine
we are united and determined uh that
will be the first message when we
wouldn't want to send out uh and uh in
terms of taking stock of the situation
in Ukraine this is something which we
focused on we see a on the one hand a
very United position on the part of the
European Union in view in particular of
the developments over the last weekend
in Russia showing the fragility and
uncertainties and and division so the
United European approach
and looking in particular to to the need
to continue mobilizing finance and
Military capabilities
for Ukraine there are four particular
points which I would like to touch on
which we focused on in our discussions
on Ukraine first of all the frozen
assets we continue to believe that we
should maintain our efforts with our
partners to mobilize Assets in favor of
Ukraine and Ukraine's future secondly we
believe that Justice and accountability
must be a key issue we continue to make
progress among Europeans but also with
our partners on these issues and the
third point is security guarantee of
course this is a key issue and we're
sending out a clear message on the part
of the European Union as key
stakeholders in this debate we're just
two weeks from the forthcoming NATO
Summit in business many of our EU member
states are also NATO members many but
not all and the fourth Point Belarus we
are paying particular attention to this
issue we were able to have an exchange
of views uh stressing the importance of
following up developments in Belarus in
the coming weeks and months so that that
was on the war in Ukraine secondly
security and defense in Versailles just
over a year ago
we are the heads of state and government
coming together to define the framework
to strengthen security and defense
efforts at EU level with including
industrial strategy production
capacity and circumstances have meant
that we've had to speed up our progress
on these matters just a few hours after
the beginning of the all-out invasion of
Ukraine by Russia it is the European
Union
which via the high representative
decided to mobilize
Military Support including lethal
military support and this is a real
turning point in the history of the
European Union
uh this no doubt was was the beginning
of European uh defense
so it was very indeed important too to
have a meeting with Jen stoltenberg of
NATO stressing the partnership between
the EU and NATO which is a key part of
the Declaration which was confirmed a
few months ago and that applies to in
the case of the task force which has
been put in place by the European
commission and NATO on critical
infrastructure showing that we are
giving real substance to the need for
complementarity between NATO and the EU
coming now to a third issue
migration on this issue I would just
like to mention that since February
um since the February concert we have
seen a lot of progress in terms of
working at it at the in the most
operational possible way in cooperation
between the council and the rotating
presidencies and the Swedish presidency
and the the commission which has made
its contribution and with leading to
conclusions on the external dimension of
migration and this was supported by 25
out of the 27 member states the reason
why we don't have European Council
conclusions but rather conclusions of
the council president
there's a dysfunction
you will have uh no doubt have have seen
uh copies of this but the reason for
that is very simple 25 member states
supports the conclusions as prepared we
had an amendment with a view to
strengthening the support for countries
which are receiving large numbers of
Ukrainian refugees there are two
countries Poland and Hungary which
believe that because of the migratory
pact and the content and the
decision-making process for the
qualified majority that they were not
prepared were not in a position to
approve or validate the conclusions that
is why we decided to opt for conclusions
by the president of the council just to
say that on the external dimension of
migration there's a very strong support
for a clear and determined approach
with
Ursula Mark rute and to George Maloney
they are working with Tunisia with a
view to cooperating on a whole wide
range of issues and initiatives and this
should enable us to reduce illegal
migratory flows and enable us to ensure
that we can
tackle this very difficult challenge the
challenge of migration we have seen of
course some tragic events which we
regularly face including a recent one in
the Mediterranean this means that Europe
has to remain very committed on this
issue and this is something to which we
have to keep coming back to and on which
we have to assume our responsibilities
another point it was a very heavy agenda
as I've said there were a lot of
important issues was relations with
China it was at the end of last year we
had a strategy debate on China on our
relationships with China it was
important today in in in in the recent
days to work all together in order to
express a United's position on China and
what's very powerful in my opinion this
is the fact that very quickly we agreed
on the conclusions on the text which
shows that the research clear European
Unity on China Unity also with our
like-minded partners because you know
that together with also love you and a
week ago we represented the European
Union in the G7 meeting in Hiroshima and
this also very important to show that we
work with our allies and like-minded
partners three pawns are very important
in my opinion in our opinion point one
reciprocity we need to rebalance the
relationship the economic relationship
with China and reciprocity is a key word
we need to address our critical
vulnerabilities we need to make sure
that we defend our interest when it
comes to the supply chains for instance
0.1 0.2 human rights Democratic Values
fundamental principles and you know that
we succeeded to relaunch the human
developed with China which is an
important step and we felt in the
meeting a lot of support to work forward
and to address those fundamental
principles and values and point three
the the global challenges uh Health
climate change Security on all those
thresholds we need to engage with China
we need to have a dialogue with China
and it is very sure and and it's
absolutely certain that because of the
war launched by Russia against Ukraine
we need to do everything to encourage
China to defend the U.N Charter to
defend the territorial integrity and
sovereignty of Ukraine and this is the
reasons for this political dialogue we
are all engaging with the Chinese
authorities this is an important message
that we send today because there is a
clear direction we know what we want we
know exactly how we would like to work
and we are all on the same page and then
finally one last one that we tricky I
I'm sorry to be so so long that time one
very last word on the economy situation
this fundamental to to build on our
fundamental strength uh if we would like
uh to be to be an influential power to
defend our interest to defend our
fundamental values we need to build on
our strengths the internal Market the
competitiveness that's why for the
members it's important to agree on the
idea to put in place a high level
group and high level Committee in order
to identify what are the additional
steps we can make in the future in order
to to to to deepen the senior market to
deepen our economic basis and we had
also the occasion in relationship with
that very important debate to this
resist concept of Economic Security and
you know that uh in Hiroshima the G7
again with a like-minded partners with
decision to discuss this topic is the
first time at the level of the leader
that had the occasion following the
communication presented by the
commission the tradition to disturb the
treasure and we feel it there is an
interest to Major progress on that child
said but also to to to make sure that we
don't lose some very important elements
for us an open economy that we don't
lose also all the the principles that
helped us in the past to build a very
strong economic model in the interest of
the European Union citizen this is a
first step the first step today you will
look at the conclusions how the leaders
have decided to to put some principles a
first step but this is very clear this
is not the last time that we discussed
expression of Economic Security I
stopped here again thank you thank you
for the root preparation of that
meeting
recognition
let me just conclude by saying once
again that we've got across message of
Unity on Central points and the European
Council will have an opportunity to come
back to these same issues again in the
next few weeks and month Madam president
you're next
um
me too I want to congratulate you to a
very successful Swedish presidency
thanks to your leadership thanks to the
very hard work of your team amazing and
fantastic results so
um really many many thanks for the
excellent cooperation that we have
experienced over the last six months we
had also a very packed agenda indeed in
this European Council and I want on one
hand to pay tribute of the whole
presidency and including this our
Council EU council's discussion
first on Ukraine
um if your presidency was crucial to
help maintain Europe's iron-clad unity
in support of Ukraine
we've seen over the weekend the Mutiny
of the Wagner group and the obvious
cracks
that have appeared in Putin system so
now it's the time to really double down
on our support for Ukraine and this was
discussed today in many different topics
for example on the military side under
your presidency the member states agreed
to use 2 billion euros from the European
peace facility to procure ammunition for
Ukraine we have already delivered over
220 000 ammunition rounds and over 2 000
missiles and we are now well on track to
deliver the 1 million rounds which are
foreseen in within the next 12 months
also by the end of the year we will have
trained more than 30 000 Ukrainian
servicemen and service women right now
we have already reached 24
000 so we are over achieving
um what the deliverable of the goal is
concerned
um or this thanks to the support of your
presidency
on the financial side
all told now almost 500 days into this
atrocious war that Russia Unleashed we
have mobilized 70 billion euros for
Ukraine since the beginning of the war
and last week we have dispersed 9
billion euros of our 18 billion MFA
package that is the MFA for the whole of
the year 2023.
we have as you know also made progress
on sanctioning Russia last week we
adopted the 11th package of sanctions
that is basically targeting loopholes
and circumvention of sanctions
we have made Solid progress on
accountability on our work to bring
Russia's crime to Justice in your
presidency I want to thank you for your
support in setting up the international
center for the prosecution of the crime
of aggression against Ukraine
and during this European Council we have
discussed the topic of immobilized
Russian assets
we the commission will come forward with
a proposal and we will focus prudently
on the windfall profits from the
immobilized assets of the Russian
Central Bank
or if your presidency has also been
extremely active on the legislative
front and this is a lot of work behind
it
you committed to brokering agreements on
major outstanding fights I remember that
when we started the presidency in kiruna
and you did so
I counted that under your presidency
more than 27 political agreements were
reached as well as over 30 General
approaches from Council
and thanks to this work we were able to
finish negotiations on the fit for 55
package it's the heart of the European
green deal it's a centerpiece of the
European green deal many thanks for this
major achievement
on the digital transition you broke at
an agreement on one of the cornerstones
of our digital Europe roadmap that is
the famous chips Act
and your presidency is ending in style
with a key political agreement reached
on Tuesday on the data Act
I also want to thank you for making
Europe's competitiveness and Europe's
attractiveness economic attractiveness
one of the governing dominant themes of
your presidency
it was a timely decision
it sent a strong signal to our industry
in the middle of a fierce Global Tech
race
we've been very successful for example
in your presidency in reducing one of
the main obstacles that is the energy
prices
it's an essential factor for our
competitiveness here in the European
Union just let me give you two figures
the wholesale electricity prices are now
80 percent lower than at their peak in
August last year and the whole gas
prices are even 90 percent lower than
August last year this is a collective
European achievement but it is built on
many concerted actions
of course our competitiveness is much
more than only energy I remember that we
had very intensive exchanges with
Business Leaders of the European
industry and indeed this was very
valuable input to the green deal
industrial plan our to-do list if I may
call it that way it is deepening our
trade and investment ties to Global
Partners
reskilling upskilling our Workforce and
crucial tasks
fostering investments in strategic
Technologies we've discussed it in our
green deal industrial plan of course the
emphasis on creating finally a fully
fledged Capital markets Union was also
repeated many times today the commitment
in the European Council
and reducing the reporting obligations
on companies these are just some example
in the vast agenda that we have which we
are working on of course also in the
next weeks and months to come
this brings me to the topic China
there is a broad consensus both among
leaders here and also with our partners
in the G7 on the concept of de-risking
not decoupling
it would not be in our interest in any
case to decouple in view of the common
Global challenges
that we need to tackle and our deep
economic ties so we need to de-risk
and we need to reverse economically as
well as diplomatically economically that
means reducing our vulnerabilities in
our economic relationship that has been
the core of the discussion today about
China
let me give you some examples first for
example in trade we need to address some
critical long-lasting imbalances give
you two figures over the last 10 years
the European Union's trade deficit has
more than tripled so today it reaches
almost 400 billion euros and this is
simply not sustainable
or second example the environment our
businesses operate in too often they are
faced with unfair practices and hurdles
that impede their access to the Chinese
market while in the contrary to the
level playing this is contrary to the
Level Playing Field that Chinese
companies are benefiting from in our
single market so I hope
that the resumption of the EU China
high-level economic and trade dialogue
can help address this
a third element besides these trades
issues are very specific risks we've
discussed today too for example linked
to critical dependencies we know the
high dependency on critic raw materials
and rare earth for examples
or the vulnerabilities of our supply
chains or the the risks are linked to
potential leakage of sensitive
Technologies
all this has to be taken into account
when we speak about de-risking not
decoupling
diplomatic de-risking is also important
because we want to keep open
communication lines with China on issues
where we agree but of course also on
issues where we disagree because this
prevents misunderstandings
on issues which we disagree we have to
be very clear it was mentioned Russia's
war of aggression on Ukraine and China's
responsibility as a member of the U.N
security Council is crucial to uphold
the values of the UN Charter and has to
be addressed by us
all in all this means continued
engagement with China but following a
European approach that is based on our
interests and on our values
finally let me emphasize the excellent
work
Ulf that the Swedish presidency did on
the migration file
migration is a common challenge
that requires a European response
the general position reached by the
Council on The Pact on migration and
Asylum is a watershed moment many things
for the Intensive work that has been
done here
and we can now take it forward with the
European Parliament and of course we
count on the Spanish presidency to bring
it to a successful close
you know that this is the legal process
in parallel we're working on an
operational tasks
I have summarized in a letter to the
European Council all the different steps
that have been we have been taken taking
since the last European Council
let me highlight only a few aspects
centerpiece is that we have to crack
down on criminal criminal networks of
Smugglers and traffickers that exploit
human despair
and we should develop alternative
pathways
to help people come to the European
Union on safe ways because that breaks
the business model of the Smugglers and
the traffickers
for this approach with third countries
we need a new
comprehensive
approach with the packages that we are
able to offer to these countries to work
together and this goes from investment
for example into renewable energies
often countries with an abundance of
resources for renewable energies
to investment in skillings or education
or people-to-people contact
at the same time we aim to step up the
cooperation with those countries against
migrant smuggling
work on returns but also have a clear
concept on support of talent
Partnerships so the legal Pathways to
Europe
the second element is that we
highlighted in a different context our
concerted Outreach to Partners For
example as we did it with the Western
Balkans
they have taken major steps in the last
month thanks to your presidency to align
their visa policy with that of the
European Union
and as a result we see very clearly that
since the start of this year we have
seen a reduction of 25 of irregular
movements from that region mainly
because of the alignment of the Visa
policy
finally the third element I want to
highlight is the strengthening of the
external borders and the Improvement of
the efficiency of the Border management
the procedures at the border
here we have two pilot projects that are
set up in Bulgaria and Romania with the
support of the commission but also
frontex europol and the Asylum agency
they are now up and running
and I hope that these Pilots will serve
as a best practice to other borders
external borders for the European Union
again all many many things this was only
apart from the vast achievements of your
presidency thank you very much for the
excellent cooperation
thank you madam president prime minister
you have the flu thank you so much
three simple keywords
safer Greener Freer
to help EU become Greener safer and
Freer that was the three priorities when
Sweden
on January 1st took over the presidency
and that is also what we have tried to
stay focused on
I have to say it's been truly both
rewarding and great fun honestly to be
holder of the presidency
also a lot of hard work exactly as I
expected and exactly as it should be
of course I'm not really neutral in this
but I also do believe that this
presidency has been successful so let me
simply allow me simply to highlight a
few reasons why
first the unity in support for for
Ukraine the European unity and the
transatlantic Unity extremely important
support Ukraine of course contributes to
a safer Europe in the worst of times
during the Swedish presidency we have
tried to keep this Unity among all the
27 countries all the time we have agreed
on a 10th and an 11th as was mentioned
sanction package against Russia and
we've agreed on a million artillery
grenades to Ukraine
we've taken initiatives to put the issue
of frozen assets the complicated issue
of frozen assets I should underline on
the table
to some extent be able to contribute to
rebuilding Ukraine and we've negotiated
the continuation of the temporary free
trade liberalization
and we will continue to support Ukraine
for as long as it takes as we always
stress
second migration I think we have reached
what many perhaps thought was almost
impossible the important agreement in
the Council on the migration Pact
an issue that has obviously divided the
member states for a very long time ended
finally in a surprisingly broad Unity as
Charles just mentioned with this
agreement migration pressure on the EU
will reduce which is important for the
entire Union
another major task during our presidency
was to make Europe greener which brings
me to the third reason I want to to
highlight today our ambition was to get
one of the world's biggest climate
packages done the fit 455 and some
people did laugh at the name of it
people don't laugh any longer because
people realize how important this is
during the presidency we have passed the
finish line
to be slightly more concrete regarding
some of the important parts in this huge
climate package agreement on
infrastructure for charging electrical
cars in the entire EU the ban against
sales for of fossil driven cars from
2035 more sustainable fuels in shipping
and in aviation and expanded emission
trading more sectors are now being
included
but what is most important is not every
single act by themselves but the whole
package
there will now be a maximum for all
carbon emissions within the union all
member states will have a climate goal
that is regulated by law and has to be
followed
this creates a whole new playing field
and sets new ground for all EU countries
their own very important efforts and by
2050 Europe will be the world's first
climate neutral continent that is a
great commitment
and last but not least I wanted to
highlight a fourth reason a Freer Europe
the presidency has continued the work
with the rule of law within the EU not
least with the rule of law Symposium
last week in Stockholm during the Spring
we have managed to put competitiveness
also on top of the agenda economy is
driving a Freer Europe as well
European businesses have been lagging
behind for the past decade compared to
our International competitors not least
in the US in many Asian countries
we see for example how the tech industry
is dominated by the American West Coast
and the Chinese East Coast but it is my
strong view that EU rules are supposed
to make it easier not harder to run
businesses in Europe and competitiveness
have not only been put on the agenda but
we now have a strategy in place and we
will follow up on it
I want to finish by reaching out a huge
thank you to all my European colleagues
but not least to you Ursula and you
Charles for being so extremely
constructive and Cooperative it's been a
privilege to serve this presidency and
as I told our colleagues in the room
Ursula I will miss our Sunday evening
telephone conversations
you don't have to be polite and say you
will do that as well but for me it's
been a privilege to have this so this
third Swedish presidency is now over but
the efforts I think to make Europe safer
Greener and Freer they continue thank
you so much
thank you prime minister and as his
customary we'll take a few questions
from our Swedish colleagues first of
um Andreas I hope I pronounce it well
from Radio Sweden please Andreas thank
you
but it's a difficult name
um a question for um prime minister uh
but also the presidents on migration if
I may
um
the d-long migration is seen as one of
the major achievements during the
Swedish presidency but the decision was
taken by a qualified majority and we've
seen the last couple of days and also
here at the summit that at least two
countries are not very happy with that
and one can also draw parallels to the
um the decision a couple of years ago
with the temporary mechanism for
relocation which really divided member
states deeply
and so my question is do you think that
was it really worth the um the uh was it
worth it to force the decision within
the council to use qualified majority
and uh or do you fear that this might
lead to new divisions among member
states and do you really think that this
could be that you could agree on this
um in the trial logs before the the um
the EU election thank you
well the answer is absolutely yes it was
not only worth it it was necessary I
think we had a very broad majority in
the council and even bigger majority now
uh de facto 25 out of 27 countries then
we fully respect the the rules that we
play play according to of course but I
think it was an overwhelming support for
for the decisions that has been made in
the councils I think this is a very good
foundation for the work that that still
is ahead of us
Regina I have a question for you as well
from SVT hi uh
SVT one question in Swedish if I'm a
um
now we've just got a week or so left
before the big uh NATO uh Summit in
Vilnius what about the Quran burning in
uh
Sweden have you had any contact with
turkey on that I'm just wondering how
this would actually impact on the
discussions between turkey Finland and
Sweden business well in Swedish
now we have ongoing contacts with uh
um turkey we've got the high level
meeting next week before the Vilnius
Summit I don't think I want to go into
that now
now not everything that is legal is
appropriate we're living in difficult uh
security policy terms that we have to
show
uh decency towards one another so that
you can have a constructive dialogue and
uh you know some people have a
completely different agenda
foreign
yes that's a very useful clarification I
have three questions and I would like to
start with you Mrs Wonderland you've
stressed unity and support for Ukraine
but I'm rather surprised to hear Mr
Orban saying about your proposal to
raise the budget which uh and he says no
30 billion uh destined for Ukraine what
are you going to do if Mr Orban says
continues to say no to support and
finance for Ukraine president Michelle
you mentioned that a number of member
states said that they did not agree with
the decision-making process I would just
like to ask
whether one can continue enlarging to 35
countries and continue at the same time
making decisions by unanimity this is
one of the key points for reflection you
have raised and in view of what happened
today perhaps this is sending out a very
negative
message and for you uh prime minister
christerson you are a member of a
coalition and you have support on the
far right
it is traditional for presidencies to be
neutral to see compromises and get them
agreed I'd just like to ask what you
have agreed on migration will that be
accepted by the extreme right which
supports you in Parliament yes yes
please so
um today there was no explicit
discussion on the mff revision and no
specific decision was being asked to be
taken by the leaders therefore we are at
the beginning of the process and we have
to discuss
fact is we have an mff that has been
constructed before the big crisis and as
you know it's a seven year budget and it
is totally programmed now within the
last 16 months as long as this war wages
now
we have taken from the EU budget 30
billion euros to support Ukraine
financially not to speak of the other
activities that we have done
and these have basically been from the
flexibilities that we have in the
cushions that we have in such a budget
these are now depleted this last till
the end of 2023 now the political
question is that we will have to discuss
in the next weeks to come
that the Outlook Beyond 2023 till the
end of the financing period 27 how are
we going to support Ukraine I think this
is the main political question that has
to be discussed was not the topic of
today
um and will first be uh certainly
discussed also with the finance
ministers
yes as regards the second question about
and the enlargement process is true that
over recent months a number of important
issues have been up for decision
recognizing for example Canada's status
for Ukraine and Moldova European
perspective for Georgia they're
important decisions with respect to the
Western Balkans so the decision-making
process is indeed a prayer discussion
and at the outset of the European
Council based on a letter which I sent a
few weeks a few days ago we decided to
start looking to our strategy for the
future of the European Union
this will begin under the Spanish
presidential reconcluted during the
Belgium presidency as regards an
argument there are two aspects firstly
those countries which want to join the
European Union must do their job put in
place the necessary reforms and we're
clear that the European commission and
the council about the expectations we
have in terms of the required standards
and governance combating corruption
separation of powers Independence of the
Judiciary there is a a meticulous and
objective analysis of these matters by
the European commission which is then
accepted or Not by the the member states
then there is a responsibility on the 27
heads of state of government in terms of
the absorption capacity looking in other
words at the impact that enlargement
might have if and when it happens on
three issues firstly our decision-making
process and you've referred to that
today the policies uh in place uh and
how these are funded it's a very complex
and difficult discussionism difficult
starting points but that doesn't mean
that we should be afraid of this debate
we have had debates on difficult issues
and based on
mutual respect and a spirit of
compromise we look for ways forward and
convergence and I'm quite confident
really on on the whole that this debate
which is now beginning will enable us in
my view to reach uh convergence on ways
that will enable us to ensure the
coherence and consistency of our
political policy yeah
I'm afraid my my old school French is
not sufficient for
answering such interesting questions so
I'll speak to English
well first just word about Sweden and
the European Union I mean in all
countries there is a ongoing in best
case fresh and vital debate on EU
mattress on what should the EU do what
should you not do or what is do what are
we doing well and less well in Sweden
eight out of eight parties represented
in Parliament are in favor of the
Swedish EU membership that says
something obviously there are different
views on exactly what to do in Brussels
and exactly what to do domestically but
still there is a very very strong
support there is also a very strong
support for what we have done in terms
of the migration pact and also in the
formalized sense since we have a a
method of anchoring every step we take
in in the EU in a specific or a special
parliamentary committee for every
decision being made so on I feel very
very secure and very safe in that
we have a very large delegation of
Ukrainian journalists yes you have came
if I'm not mistaken from Ukraine foreign
question to president Michelle uh we
know that the EU has made a political
decision to ramp up well first of all to
come to commonly procure uh defense
equipment ammunition uh therefore to
ramp up production
is there uh a discussion ongoing between
the leaders to involve somehow the
Ukrainian defense industry in the
process of production of Defense
equipment of ammunition of military
equipment at least to cover some of the
needs precisely of the Ukrainian Army on
the battlefield
um so first question and I have question
to president from the line and prime
minister Christensen
we also know that the EU generally
supports extensively supports the uh
peace formula proposed by president
zielinski and we know that the peace
formula Summit is going to happen one
day but is there any Clarity today on
the timetable for that Summit and on its
agenda and what are the modalities of
future security guarantees for Ukraine
thank you
this is very clear that I will not share
all the the details regarding the the
closed coordination between the
Ukrainian authorities and the European
member states in terms of military
cooperation and Military coordination
but one thing is absolutely clear what
we are doing uh with the the massive
support uh we are bringing to Ukraine in
terms of military treatment is making
the military the military the the the
Ukraine Army closer to the European
Union and closer to Nato this is what's
happening with the decisions we have
taken the FED it will provide military
equipment the fact that we are working
on the the military prediction it was in
that direction and uh I'm absolutely uh
confident that we will make a lot of
progress because we understand on the EU
side that we really need to adapt our
industrial strategy in order to make
sure that it will be in line with our
ambition for a real European defense
so
we all want peace and nobody wants more
peace than the Ukrainian people without
any question and therefore it is very
good that president zelenski came
forward with the 10-point peace formula
it is an excellent basis or Foundation
to move on because every single point
every single word is deducted from the
UN Charter or un resolutions so broad
support globally for the principles that
are enshrined in this peace formula
what a peace Summit is concerned it's of
course the decision of Ukraine and the
Ukrainian government went to table it
when to invite to a peace Summit but I
just wanted to flex strong support from
our side to the what the peace formula
of President zielinski is concerned the
security guarantees will be discussed
intensively in the next weeks to come
with around the NATO Summit in Williams
I think very important is also as a
supporting element for developing
security guarantees that Ukraine is
impressively engaging in reforms to
strengthen the country to fight
corruption to have a clear program to
anti-money laundering to have a sound
strong judicial system and as the
commission is following up with the
Ukrainian government on the development
of these reforms I can witness that this
speed and the determination in which
they deliver their reforms is impressive
I fully Sheriff Russell's assessment
Italian you had a question as well you
will have to go to the stand or stand up
please thanks thank you
Hungarian journalist I have two
questions the first I would address to
the president of the commission arriving
in Brussels prime minister Orban posted
a video message on Facebook where he
asked where the money had gone and he
said that Brussels is now asking for
billions and billions most of it for
Ukraine while it cannot account for the
budget
which it has brought to the edge of
bankruptcy now my question is whether Mr
Urban asked you where the money went if
he did what was your reply if he didn't
what would you answer to him and the
second question if I made to prime
minister christerson
Hungary has delayed the ratification of
the NATO accession of Sweden until
otun
do you think it is a Revenge because
Sweden as president of the EU Council
pushed through a quality a qualified
majority voting in the Council on two
import important migration files thank
you very much
so to your first question no he did not
and
what I would have answered as you asked
me what I would have answered if he
would have asked me is
um we all can Witness
that the European Union is strong and
prosperous that is good
and we have a very transparent system of
checks and balances the court of
Auditors the parliament the council just
to name three that is very good this is
necessary in a strong democracy
and therefore we are also so strongly
supporting the principle of rule of law
mainly also to fight corruption and to
make sure that there is clear
accountability and transparency in any
kind of Institutions that we have in the
European Union
I have
twice I have spoken to prime minister
Orban about the Swedish ratification or
the Hungarian ratification of the
Swedish
NATO membership last time was yesterday
and both times he has he has confirmed
that Hungary will not delay the Swedish
accession they will not delay the
Swedish succession and I I think that is
a message that is is good enough for me
Sam from the ftes Sam
thanks one question on the Frozen uh
sorry immobilized Russian Central Bank
assets there have been concerns
expressed by the European Central Bank
as well as some member states about the
implications of um some sort of levy on
the proceeds of those assets for the
status of the Euro and also for
financial stability and I wondered if
you could all comment on first of all do
you how do you respond to those concerns
and do you think that those concerns can
be overcome in order for the 27 to come
round a proposal by the end of the year
thank you
we we had indeed a good debate on the
traffic it's not the first time that uh
education to address that uh the topics
of the Frozen asset and I think there's
a common role a common political will we
think it would be fair to to use a part
of that money in order to support the
future of Ukraine on the other hand we
we are serious and we would like to take
into account all the elements that need
to be addressed and see two important
points some comments made by the central
events is one thing but also the need to
coordinate with our like-minded partners
and and and that's why also in the G7
meeting we had the occasion through this
just that creation to distrust that
opinion what we did uh on the sanctions
for instance the very close cooperation
the very close to ordination I think
that we need to follow the same approach
and we took note that the commission
intends to make a proposal on the
question and then the Democratic process
the decision-making process will allow
everyone to uh to to decide what will be
its position
so indeed there are
two dimensions one is the police
dimension
see the massive destruction that Russia
is responsible for in Ukraine
and the perpetrator has to be held
accountable
it cannot be that Russia destroys
vast parts of the infrastructure of
Ukraine
and is not contributing to the repair
and reconstruction of that that is the
political dimension now the financial
Dimension the immobilized assets
indeed we will have a very prudent
approach
to work with the windfall profits
in close cooperation with our
International partners
I think trust is very important
therefore we take the concerns and
comments of the ECB
um very serious and into account that is
part of developing the
procedure
but I would like to recall that the
first and most important step
was and is the seizing of the assets
itself
16 or 15 months ago
and this is not allow a long time ago
and the reactions have been very calm
and I think this is also an indication
that it is very well understood
The Prudent approach that we are
choosing
and allow meologists to add on to that
that is a good precondition for for
coming steps and coming decision making
is of course the the high level group we
we named uh to make or to do all the job
to investigate exactly how how is the
situation and what are the legal
preconditions
I have one more question
um
you have the last question today
thank you Maria address
I'd like to come back to what happened
regarding migration you said that a lot
of progress has been made on this
subject and yet you have a sense of kind
of deja vu here at the European Council
Poland and Hungary they seem to be
calling into account a decision-making
process laid down
uh in the treaties but they seem to be
saying that they won't comply with any
agreement on the rules and I'm just
wondering if you're worried about this
what are the risks which arise when it
comes to the showing solidarity managing
migration and also more generally on how
the EU works
now I was the European Council a few
years ago when there was a lot of
tension around migration I get the
impression now that when it comes to the
substance and the operational way of
taking this forward things have moved
forward a lot
um I think we had an important step
taken
with the qmv adoption of the impact and
the Swedish prime minister was quite
right to say that a few days ago we've
validated
uh The Pact there with a few abstentions
a few votes against but here today we've
had 25 out of 27 in favor so that's an
additional step forward so the reality
is that we've got 25 member states who
were mobilized to support this to
implement the uh pact uh dealing with
the external dimension of all this and
you've seen the presidency conclusions
on this and then we've had two member
states that have said that they
disapprove of this they're against me
you'll have to speak with them directly
on that
but now we've had a a proper respectful
debate on this and guarantor of that now
they said that they were against the
substance that the migration pact and
they also disliked the decision-making
model I either use of qualified majority
voting but that's what's in the treaty
as you quite rightly said and the reason
for that is that they have a different
interpretation of previous European
Council conclusions but we've got 25 out
of 27 member states who interpret those
conclusions in the same way there are 25
that want to work on the internal and
external dimensions and we've got two
countries saying that they can't sign up
to this for the two reasons that I've
just given quite uh transparently let's
keep a level ahead let's stay calm here
we're going to continue to work on this
to continue implementing this the
migration practice being validated it
needs implementing let's hope the trilog
will take things forward and
externally we've got a lot of uh
commitment here heads of state and
government working with me with the
commission president working with uh
presidents of third countries it shows
that we're actually generating Real
Results in areas where we really need to
improve migration management visas
investment cooperation to break the
business model of traffickers so that's
what we're talking about here and there
this
debate of several hours yesterday was
very useful it didn't show unanimity
there wasn't unanimity but there's a
great deal of convergence here which was
uh
and not at all there just a few years
ago when we had real tension in the EU
around migration issues and prime
minister a special word of thanks also
to the Swedish presidency press team
we've done a wonderful job see you in
July
thank you
[Music]
foreign
remember
this is
foreign